c'est nouveau ça tu la fais juste pour
la rumba
non mais parce que j'avais fait un petit
moment que ce que j'aime bien chez sa
mine
j'adore cadeau de tatouages oui oui là
c'est un pistolet dans le coup ensuite
des ailes d'ange c'est la date de
naissance de ma grand-mère d'ailleurs
que j'embrasse elle s'est fait mal aux
eaux
elle nous regarde je t'aime allez allez
donc l année en misant ribéry dont les
noms comme les 137 est bas et en heure
non non non maintenant est sûre qu'est
steve biko ouais ça ça a énormément fait
réagir est ce que ça vous a choqué ou
pas sur le plateau alors énorme alors
que derrière je voulais juste vous dire
cette séquence à fait normal a fait
énormément réagir notamment louve silva
mais si c'est un poisson dans l'eau des
jacuzzis un des points ce soir
honnêtement oui moi tout ce qui touche
aux animaux je suis jamais deux jeunes
dépend énormément la fondation bardot
[Rires]
d'où des animaux mais c'est des crues
les poissons évidence les brestois c'est
des crabes
non mais peu importe pourquoi on serait
moins triste pour des poissons que pour
un mouton
je veux dire ce sont des animaux sont
des êtres vivants chose aux animaux je
suis pas bien et je défends 200000
espace nabila ben ouais mais ce qu'il
dit ils ont même pas de sens les
poissons pâtes riz à tanger à cannes
quand j'étais à cannes on m'a dit que ma
robe
elle me faisait penser à elle ni ride
oh les gars est elle à vélo précédés
belle chanteuse mais reina
[Musique]
exactement je le connaissais pas du tout
et l'exercice est arrivé comme ça il m'a
dit d'imiter donc avec naulleau qui est
un libraire
[Rires]
il adore
mais j'adore pour la lula en fait
j'avais décrit nuages mais également ses
deux balles à trois trios hb et e
qu'est-ce que vous avez n'est pas des go
sont 5000 euros la route s'arrêter chez
moi je prends la robe je vais acheter un
appart avec à la taille de keddy la robe
faisait juste 200 e
c'était l'eau sans douleur